and we're learning more about the 17
people killed in the Southern California
mudslides the victims who died during
the storm and mudflows early Tuesday
range in age from 3 to 89 4 of them were
children
authorities say the death toll could
rise 43 people are considered missing
Carter Evans met a man who was caught in
the mudslide and lost his partner 17
years Carter is in heavily damaged
Montecito good morning good morning you
know when you look at all this
destruction it's hard to imagine that
anyone could have survived being swept
away in a debris flow like this in fact
a body was found right over there the
other day
and now people are questioning what
happened how long did it take it we're
getting first-hand accounts from
survivors who lost loved ones this is
all I have everything is gone all la la
Barajas has left to remember his life
partner Peter flore are these mementos
he found about a half-mile from their
home he says they lived in a voluntary
evacuation zone so they decided to ride
out Tuesday's storm the floor felt like
he had no support at all it just was
rolling underneath me the walls just
burst opened the mud came in and just
shot us both out of the house they were
soon pulled in different directions
the last thing Peter yelled out to me
was la la grab onto some wood and don't
let go and that was the last I heard of
him officials said they tried to give
people living in the area ample warning
starting the weekend before the storm
via emails text messages and phone calls
when the storm finally hit the National
Weather Service put out a we alert which
is similar to an Amber Alert saying that
flash flooding was imminent the alert
went to the Thomas fire area at 2:46
a.m. but Santa Barbara officials were
concerned it didn't reach certain
Verizon customers they then issued a
countywide alert at 3:51 when the debris
flow was already started officials
answer criticism Thursday that those
alerts came too late we knew we couldn't
put a weir out when we were doing the
evacuation orders and warnings because
it would have gone out to the entire
county would have caused great confusion
I don't think they could have ever saw
this coming but I think that if they had
said everybody should leave we wouldn't
have seen as many people in this
situation right now
well the Office of Emergency Management
says it's looking into ways to approve
improve the alert system the sheriff's
office says it issued voluntary and
mandatory evacuation orders it was just
working off the best information they
had but the rain felt much harder and
much faster than expected
John it's heartbreaking Carter thanks